before we ready player one let's get
down wave that's right spawn sunshine
this video is sponsored by audible go to
audible.com slash John's or text John's
- 500 500 - get yourself a free 30-day
trial of audible and snag yourself a
free audiobook all that in a bit but for
now let's ready player one
[Music]
ready player one funny I was a younger
brother so I was always player two
you're the younger brother you get
screwed with Luigi you just have to play
as Luigi the way it is so ready player
one is a movie directed by Steven
Spielberg it's based off of a book that
blew up a lot of people got this blood
and people like me who got it for free
and Luke rate still haven't read it in
ready player one there is this virtual
online world that the entire populace is
enthralled with called the Oasis that's
Oasis not beyond Oasis that's deep cut
be our MMO with monetary value the
Creator played by Mark Rylance has died
he left an easter egg in this virtual
world whoever finds this easter egg will
become the sole proprietor the owner of
the Oasis and now everyone's looking for
it that's right taking over or owning
the actual world that motivation died
with Pinky and the brain being the owner
of a virtual world that's more beloved
than this shitty actual world yeah I'll
get behind that we have ourselves a
pretty sweet adventure I was really
enthralled with this movie not only
because of the nostalgia throwbacks
which they're in here this challenge is
a big thing right now you see nostalgic
throwbacks and a lot of entertainment
this movie more than most you do get why
it's there not just a throwback it's a
mechanic or it's a throwback that's just
a throwback that's painted like a
mechanic I found myself enthralled with
our team of heroes ever since the online
world became a thing people have been
hiding their identity it's an
opportunity to be someone different be
something different it was back then
it's wait is now the way it will be in
the future but the reason this hits all
the right notes is also the villain Ben
Mendelsohn is just great at playing a
corporate dick villain he is in fact
such a corporate dick parasitic villain
of the video game world the only
unbelievable thing is that though there
isn't in his name there is no a but it's
that corporate disconnect this guy in
his company they don't play games
they're there for the value of it or
they're for all the wrong reasons
whereas the youth are there for the
right reasons to real stick it to the
man message [ __ ] just stick it to the
man and dressed like this see though
this movie does have throwback so it's a
celebration of the past it's also a
celebration of a future possibly to come
I can totally see a virtual world like
this happening social media is a thing
vr gaming is a thing cryptocurrency is a
thing when their powers combined they
will become Captain Planet or you know a
virtual world and we shall all disappear
to experience something we have never
experienced in our lives to experience
for the first time actual safe sex ever
we were all like Bitcoin what's that oh
it's a really valuable thing we probably
all
have gotten in on earlier there is value
in a virtual currency it's real this
movie illustrates that very effectively
and the last act of this movie it hit me
I need to see this movie like seven more
times
I need my head on a swivel man just to
get all the references lose of one
reference in particular I was like that
I thought I was the only one that
awesome because that's a sweet weapon we
all know it never expected to see that
reference in here but a day but one
thing that I can see being a crime is
that when they're in the game world it's
great when they're out of the game world
you're like can we get back into the
game world you know when things are
interesting and cool storytelling wise
how do you feel like it works the game
world is supposed to be more interesting
than the actual world in this movie if
they were on par with each other if they
were as interesting or the real world
was slightly more interesting you'd be
like why do people escape to this video
game world in fact that the video game
world is so much more interesting than
the real world you get it you're like
okay I get why people escape into this
thing I don't actually need the plot to
tell me why I see why the biggest
negative in this movie there's someone
in this movie that I actually set in my
head I was like how did she get this
role she's not a major character she's a
minor character but how was she did some
producer go hey Spielberg you have to
use her feel like Spielberg would be
above that but maybe not guys in the end
this movie hit me I didn't like it I
loved it this is a fantastic Steven
Spielberg adventure that brings
Spielberg back to making movies that
just bring out the inner child in all of
us a fantastic adventure that appeals to
kids and appeals to adults the reason I
started loving Spielberg in the first
place if you're a young movie fan or
video gamer you'll get it if you are an
older movie fan possibly an older video
gamer you will get it this movie is the
great unifier very effectively so ready
player one is definitely worth watching
and definitely worth buying on blu-ray
fun nostalgia bomb and a great adventure
go see it and remember - that's right
spawn so sure this video is sponsored by
audible home to the largest audiobook
library in the known universe follow the
link below to audible.com slash John's
or text John's - 500 500 - get yourself
a 30-day free trial of audible and your
free audiobook that's right most
sponsorships give you one thing to
audiobook recommendation simple I love
me the science astrophysics for people
in a hurry by Neil deGrasse Tyson
because in a hurry and audible seems to
work for me going to work the long
drives to clogged freeways that's where
audible comes into play for me so if you
can get
science on in the meantime I'm gonna
count that as another cool thing I gave
you that makes three so click on the
link below to audible.com slash John's
or text John's to five hundred five
hundred and science the [ __ ] out of your
life alright so ready player one have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know or this is actual question if I
started a twitch channel and a twitch
stream would you watch it this is data
this is me a crewing data here need to
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]